the U.S and China are two of the world's
biggest cotton producers the U.S exports
most of its cotton and its biggest
customer is China which bought nearly 3
billion dollars of American cotton last
year at the same time China exports the
largest share of its finished textiles
to the U.S but the balance of that
relationship is shifting
in 2021 President Joe Biden signed a law
Banning imports from China's main cotton
growing region in xinjiang home of
millions of uyghurs and other ethnic
minorities human rights groups have
accused China of detaining as many as 1
million people and forcing them into
labor which China has repeatedly denied
the impact of banning this cotton in
China can't be overstated U.S cotton
prices surged after many American
companies scrambled for new cotton
sources China even started importing
more American cotton since lots of its
domestic Supply couldn't be used for
goods sent to the U.S but now those
Imports have been declining this comes
at a time when U.S cotton farmers were
already struggling due to lower prices
and drought and because China is so
enmeshed in the cotton supply chain
plenty of shinjang cotton is still
making it into the U.S according to
companies that do forensic testing of
cotton apparel here's how the U.S effort
to Stamp Out forced labor has impacted
the cotton Market in both countries
the U.S grows about 12 of the world's
cotton China grows more than double that
about 26 percent and China isn't just
the world's biggest grower of cotton
it's a key processor of it too
the Garment processing textile
processing industry really isn't based
that much in the United States anymore
so it goes overseas China is a big
destination but then you also have
Bangladesh Vietnam Sri Lanka according
to estimates from December 2022 China
milled about 35.5 million bales of
cotton last year the U.S milled about
2.3 million Bales China has remained a
key player in the cotton supply chain
but its role has been shifting more and
more other countries like Vietnam
Pakistan and Bangladesh have been
importing raw cotton Milling it into
yarn and then sending the yarn to China
it is kind of tough to know
um you know where exactly your cotton is
coming from I think the way that a lot
of these facilities work it's really
tough to audit whether or not you know a
Chinese Mill for example is using cotton
that's come from xinjiang or from
elsewhere in the world as cotton gets
cleaned purified and finished via a
complicated supply chain it becomes
harder and harder to know where the
original cotton came from which makes it
easier for companies to dodge import
restrictions
then there's the final stage of the
process using yarn or fabric to make the
finished goods China also Leads Here U.S
trade statistics suggest U.S Imports of
cotton products from China have
decreased over the last decade though
the country is still the biggest source
of U.S cotton textiles and apparel the
U.S meanwhile makes few of its own
finished goods one trade Group found
less than three percent of apparel sold
in the U.S last year was produced
domestically though those figures
weren't specific to Cotton we live in a
hyper globally competitive Marketplace
you've seen a decimation of critical
aspects of our industry Kim glass is the
president and CEO of the National
Council of textile organizations which
represents domestic manufacturers she
says goods made by forced labor in China
make it impossible for American
businesses to compete in the cotton
supply chain it's pennies that moves and
shifts production globally from one
country to another and particularly on
the areas of xinjiang and forced labor
associated with those cotton Supply
chains that has had a severe economic
impact on the U.S domestic textile
industry importers have to document the
products they're bringing into the U.S
but this doesn't always tell the whole
story U.S Customs and Border Protection
detain some Goods that its risk
assessment tools flag as potentially
illegal and importers are required to
present additional documentation to get
them released but some like glass say
enforcement of the ban has been
insufficient the numbers are completely
underwhelming on enforcement activities
a few dozen shipments stopped per month
we're talking about thousands and
millions of packages coming in that
contain apparel items we should be
seeing stop shipments off the port of LA
every day the clearest way to know where
an item comes from is to test its
chemical components and DNA Customs test
some imports but many companies also do
their own to validate their supply
chains cotton is a plant and it has to
just like you and I take in nutrients so
you can analyze those nutrients to get
an idea of where the plant was grown
applied DNA Sciences is a biotech
company based on Long Island it
specializes in supply chain tracing as
well as genetic testing and Therapeutics
we have two different colors of the same
shirt submitted by the same client both
claim to be from Brazil
one of them tested clearly as being from
Brazil and it matched with our library
Brazilian samples while the other one
matched with Xing
there would be no way on Iraq to tell
they would be right next to each other a
black and a white shirt they also do DNA
tagging spraying a molecular tag onto
raw fibers at the cotton gin so
companies can track their raw cotton
through the supply chain about 14 or 15
percent of the finished goods we test
show evidence of xinjiang cotton we tell
the people who've asked us to test that
product and then they have to push
hotter on their supply chain given the
complexity of ensuring goods from China
don't contain xinjiang cotton
LL Bean mango have cut out China
completely you see Brands moving their
operations to get around China in
general because they don't want to run
into a situation where they can't sell
in the U.S you see them moving these
companies moving their supply chains out
of China to places like Vietnam or
Bangladesh Sri Lanka you know all the
names that you see when you look at the
back of your shirt but this is missing a
major part of the story according to
experts many of these Goods may have
been processed or even made in China but
are being exported to the U.S via
another country another thing trade data
misses is a loophole that many industry
experts say allows China to ship goods
containing banned cotton into the U.S a
huge number of shipments from China
arrive through a rule called de minimis
which allows shipments worth under 800
to come into the U.S without incurring
tariffs or requiring as much paperwork
this is significantly higher than the de
minimis limit for imports to China which
is just 50 Yen less than seven dollars
some lawmakers are trying to modify this
rule to keep banned Chinese cotton out
and level the playing field for U.S
cotton Growers who have already been
dealing with decreasing prices and
drought
the uyghur force labor protection act is
ultimately designed to clamp down on
forced labor but it also has major
bearings on the U.S cotton industry
theoretically when the ban first came
into place U.S cotton Growers were
really hoping that that would give
cotton prices in general boost would
give export demand a boost which it has
to some extent but ultimately it hasn't
been enough at least so far to offset
the long-term decline of the U.S cotton
industry
foreign